what really interested us even before we
went there what kind of sparked our
curiosity when we said yes to the
project to the first commission was that
how
like what's the value of fashion in
these remote places like here you are in
greenland like why do you become a
fashion designer and also the history
not only of fashion but of clothing and
how do you cope with
basically the force of nature there like
how can you ever be fashionable in like
a snowstorm but but also then on the
other side if that impacts you as a
creative person
and a designer but how does that impact
you as a person i mean obviously you
will have a very uh oh it became it
wasn't obvious from the beginning but it
became very obvious then when we
actually did our interviews and
researches uh
on location that people are very
influenced by
of course the weather but also the year
the darkness and the light the kind of
immediate
force of nature
we use the medium of photography
but i wouldn't call us necessarily
photographers in that sort of technical
sense because none of these images are
necessarily like that 30th of a second
moment when it comes to sort of the way
that we're thinking about what the
finished image is
the image needs to portray something
beyond that moment because
i think when the it's kind of like the
persian miniatures you know you have to
put a lot into this one story
and uh it's not a book you can go
through over several pages or film it
has to all be there in that one image
like the image is worth a thousand words
and i think for us we're looking at a
much more holistic view of looking and
attacking photography and there comes in
technology there comes in also where
we're maybe
sometimes we have worked with more
analog techniques of painting or drawing
but i think overall
we like this kind of gray zone of you
wondering is this a photograph is it a
painting
is it
and maybe what we're trying to
emotionally charge the image image with
and to make you feel
in a sense is maybe more real to the
circumstance than a real honest-to-god
30th of a second image that that you
maybe feel more about what it is we're
trying to say
than just having
the image in itself be directly from
that moment and i think these sort of
moments in between is something that
we're really curious with
in all of the images that we work with
and i think that we also play with the
the
with this very embroidered and very
emotional style is something that we
love to sort of use in capturing the
viewer into the story that we that we
want to express or tell
in cities
it's a little bit harder for us to work
with our method i think we really enjoy
being in smaller
places just because we work really
intensely with people and and to make
just make the contact and kind of delve
into the network that still exists in
smaller maybe more rural areas or just
smaller places that is what interests us
and
and with the cultural side of it of
course also um it's just our our
personal interest but we've been talking
about uh getting closer to where we are
from but i think you need a little bit
of distance
you